It's time to learn with who is probably
one of the best artists of my generation -
Lady Gaga!
Are you ready?
So, she just won the Oscar for Best
Original Song, and she was in fact
nominated for a few other ones.
I recommend that you check out the speech that she made the other night at the Oscars
as it was super motivating.
I'll link that down in the description and
the movie is fantastic; it was a little long
for me, but I would still recommend that you watch it.
So, she and Bradley Cooper did a really amazing performance of the song "Shallow" live at the Oscars,
and I definitely recommend that you look that up after this lesson
if you haven't seen it yet, but today we
will be using the original music video
to teach you with this song.
And we help you every single week to understand fast speaking natives
without getting lost, without missing the jokes, and without subtitles!
So, if that sounds like something that you would like to be able to do,
then be sure to hit that Subscribe
button as well as the bell down below,
so that you don't miss a single one of our
newest lessons!
Now let's jump into today's lesson with "Shallow" from Lady Gaga.
Alright, hit that LIKE button below because every time you do
you are telling YouTube that you want to be alerted when we put out new videos,
and that way we can continue to help you on your journey to fluency.
Can you give me an example with "times"?
You could talk about any period of your life , the good times, the bad times, the crazy times,  the dark times -
Just get creative! Do that down in the comments below and I'll be correcting many of your examples.
Do you get frustrated when natives speak too fast?
Well, maybe we can help.
We created a mini-course to help you to
understand natives at any speed.
You can learn more about that by clicking up here.
If you like learning English with music, then you should totally check out this playlist of lessons that we have
teaching you English with music after you finish this lesson.
You'll find that clicking right up here.
Aww yeah! I hope you had an awesome time
learning English with Lady Gaga today.
You definitely should Subscribe because
we put out new lessons like this one
every single week.
Also, check out that mini-course I told you about earlier.
You might like this playlist of lessons
that we teach you English with the Ellen show
or check out this other lesson I think you really enjoy!
Now it's time to go outside the classroom,
and LIVE your English!
Aww yeah!